Okay, Michael, so I pulled up this webpage. We
will provide a link to it, on our own webpages.
And you'll notice there's a really nice copyright here, and
this is all free to use. So I'm not, I'm
not doing anything wrong here. They're going to use Independent Components
Analysis, as a way of recovering, original sounds. So, here
you see that I've clicked onto a police car. Somebody
talking in a commercial and, let's say, this dude here.
And, what it's going to do is it's going to, generate
sounds from each of these three sources that are all
independently generated. And, it's going to mix them. So if I
click on these icons here, of these microphones. See, these
look just like what I drew before. You'll be
able to hear each of their sounds combined together. So
I'm going to put my microphone very close to it so
you can hear it. [SOUND] [FOREIGN] And here is another
one of the microphones. [SOUND]
[FOREIGN]
Okay, so, Michael, could you hear that?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, what I did is, I played two of the, the, the
mix sounds together. And, you know, to
the untrained ear, they sound very much alike.
But I think the, the most important thing is, all three of these sounds are
over on top of one another, and as human beings we actually do a pretty
good job on being able to focus on one of them,
because I don't know, we're designed to do that. But machines have
historically had a terrible time of doing this. And independent components
analysis was the first sort of generic algorithm that was able to
solve this. So, we're going to use ICA now to separate the
sound sources. And as you see, we get these little gramaphone things.
And I'm going to play, each one of these and see if
they did a good job of separating those into the original sources.
[FOREIGN] The guardians
of the electronic stock market NASDAQ
who have been burned by past ethics questions are. [SOUND] Okay,
so wasn't that kind of cool
Michael? I mean we, we took these completely mixed up sounds and
we were able to recover the original, by using independent components analysis.
>> That's fascinating. I don't still
understand what it's doing, but its pretty
neat that it could do that, because it sounded pretty mixed up to me.
>> Well it was, it was in fact each
one of these three sources, that we eventually heard
were in fact arbitrarily, linearly, combined into each of
these separate microphones. And there's really sort of no way
in which you'd be able to recover the original sounds, because, there's
no reason for you to be able to do that. But people
do it all the time. And now with something like independent components
analysis, you can also do it. And the reason it works with
independent components analysis. And that fundamental
assumption that it's making, is that
whatever is generating in these cases
these sounds, the sources, are statistically
independent of one another. Which happens to be true in that case.
And they're combined together in a way that is a linear combination.
Now there's a lot a details here. And again
when you read the materials you see exactly how independent
components analysis works. But, intuitively all it's doing is taking
this particular model, and by using mutual information directly to
find things that are independent of one another, while
not losing any information, from the observables, it's able to
reconstruct these sounds. And it's able to do this incredibly
quickly, and incredibly well. Under a large number of conditions.